taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two foods gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking tonight oh q is back
and joining us for another episode uh i
don't know if these uh will appear in
order because uh cube bailed us out uh
when joe had to do work at joey rose's
on rivington street yes visit his
sandwich shop you led like people know
that you're part owner of that or no i
never did no because i love telling
people i say it all the time yeah i'm
not i mean it's a small investment i
mean the ti like the the tiniest
investment you could possibly like less
than a percentage but yeah as far as i'm
concerned yeah
that means it's a [ __ ] i'm part owner
man yeah yeah
uh well i told him um i told him that uh
like what i'm really buying is the
ability to be like
uh i don't like that for like in
perpetuity yeah he's the son he's a real
son of a [ __ ] too because he
lied to me to rosa he i said i'll do it
if you name a sandwich after me he said
i i'm not getting into that i'm which is
fine he's like i'm not doing that he
goes i'll name it i'll name a sandwich
called the bride guy and and and name it
after you he goes but i don't want to do
the cue
he goes but i'll do a bright guy i go
youtube right guy he's a bird guy yeah i
asked him in atlantic city i was like
how's the bright guy he's like what what
i think that was a curb episode like he
had something named that last season
yeah yeah it was the the place in l.a
that names all the sandwiches after you
and it was a good curb episode yeah yeah
oh so the bridegroom that would've been
fun but do you know what it was gonna be
we worked it all out but i don't
remember it now but i would love to get
into the lab with him and and like i
just want him to stay true to his word
or else i i might have to pull my
investment out wow
my lady might get a potato salad on the
menu yeah yes sir yes oh that's nice
yeah
so there you go although
it was promised and it's not up there
yet he's promising this [ __ ] all over
town and we also came up with a cute
little thing where like if you ordered
like um
there would be shots and the shots would
come with a skewer or something so it
was born out of pickleback shots i'm
like never mind the back why don't you
do a nice
like like a nice pickle square on a on a
toothpick when you order a whiskey so
it's an actual pickle and so we started
thinking about oh wow you could put a
gherkin on there you could put so we
started you know olives so there's all
these like accoutrements to shots
specialty shots it was supposed to be
like fun it sounds good but i haven't
seen that yet but
to be fair you're watching this now
truthfully he's only been open like a
week two weeks
so i mean it's the play is amazing yeah
just a shout out on it yeah
exactly have you heard of sandwiches no
delicious
dude i'm telling you i gotta get over
there so good yeah i keep meaning to get
over there i just haven't had a chance
you know new york we grew up in new york
yeah we'll see we'll go yeah go get a
drink i mean uh bergio for lunch
tomorrow manhattan maybe uh
tomorrow
tomorrow i might be able to i might be
able to do that let's do it i will talk
after yeah yeah um you know how we grew
up in new york and even a suburb and sat
down like a deli sandwich is a thing
yeah like you go we go out and on the
road anywhere in the midwest a lot of
times it's not the same it's not the
exact same don't have like the jimmy
john's and things like that but a
neighborhood deli that makes like a
fresh sliced sandwich it's not it's very
new york central is on highlands yeah
like an italian deli tour
and especially like bagels were famous
for that is something we grew up on and
even in manhattan right now it's hard to
find a place that isn't it's not it's
churning out like those authentic
neighborhood deli sandwiches that's what
he has the bread is freaking delicious
it's like you know when you just bite it
they're like oh and then you think about
that sandwich yeah that's what it is
yeah yeah
and he has eight on the menu and he used
to do a cold aid hop right now he just
has the a cold on the menu and they're
eight bucks
so that's that's good too i'm gonna give
a little plug because it's so good and
he already has he's already selling out
of sandwiches every day because the
neighborhood is immediately on it
because it's such a good deal so they're
like upping up these sandwiches like you
know so it's building really pretty
quickly good for him and the spot is
dope it's all like it's all nostalgic
it's built out and he has all like old
uh rap albums uh underneath the bar like
on the bar top wow
yeah on the wall he has all old laser
discs from movies
a bookshelf with all old sci-fi books
and then uh he has an old star wars
machine and then a pinball uh no it's
like the yeah yeah and then in the walls
it was this cool thing they had these
brick walls that had like whole like
literal like
cutouts in them yeah like like actually
you have one in your house i think like
that cut out and a brick wall like that
you kind of like that thing in the world
like the fire the fire yeah
and he put screens on them and put
lights in them and he put old atari
games in them so it's almost like
they're like in the in the wall like
it's kind of cool yeah anyway
over there it's on rivington street and
you go check out joey rose's uh all
right so you are uh sitting in again
today for joe and yeah love to have you
back
yeah this one i feel like i can really
tackle tackle a little bit more teeth
okay because i do have a like as opposed
to dogs versus cats you know i love them
both this i have a very i have a strong
opinion on so i feel like i could more
accurately defend yeah so if
that's the last one we did together i
guess ours won't count toward i don't
think i think we agreed to that they
won't count toward the year total we
need to check in with derosa okay okay
yeah because apparently apparently
whoever loses has to like we're doing
the season by like year which is like
right now oh yeah and whoever has the
worst record is gonna it's gonna have
some type of ill-fated thing i'm gonna
throw in the youtube community tab uh
just send us some ideas of what we
should do to the guys who who loses
what's the punishment yeah help us
so whereas last time i hated cats you
love cats but we're fine with dogs love
dogs love dogs so it was hard for you to
get mix it up but i wanted to have that
battle because me and joe couldn't have
it and you're the perfect cat person
yeah today we are going to be battling
appetizers versus desserts
the two ends of the meal two goal posts
and look
you actively don't like dessert it takes
a lot for me to have a dessert i don't
think the most i ever see you do is
maybe a sorbet at the end do a sorbet a
mango sorbet will get me every time a
lemon sorbet maybe sometimes if they
have key lime pie i'll do that yeah but
on the whole
whereas i'm like i'm saving room for
this dessert right yeah uh i love apps
but um
but
i have i thought about it because when
you prompted this this match to me which
you did i was like can i make an
argument for and again and i think that
i can okay yeah
what's up guys i am coming to your town
and you are coming uh to see me in your
town and i just jedi mind trick to you
come go to salvolcanocounty.com for all
my dates i am
traveling the most i have in three years
and i would like to shout out that we
have added second shows in chicago at
the vic theater madison at the barrymore
theater because you guys are just coming
out strong also in albany at the egg
pittsburgh at the homestead music hall
and
detroit at the royal
royal oak music theater and of course at
foxwoods in connecticut all of those
have added second shows but i'm also
gonna be making my way
to
indianapolis cleveland des moines san
diego la and actually burlington i think
we might be adding another show too so
washington dc uh that's the last date i
got you guys got to come out
salvagoniocomedy.com for tickets all in
january and february i will see you
there great so we're doing appetizers
versus desserts cues on apps i'm on
desserts uh and hold on let's
all right what is it i still love you no
matter what no matter what happens i
love you no more what happens i love you
no matter what happens i love you no
matter what happens i love you that's
what joe de rosa all right okay great
all right and it's time for and then we
say b-a-t-t-l-e buns okay okay it's time
i can't believe i'm doing this because i
don't want to hear him being like ah
okay it's time
no one can complain oh he can complain
he'll find something
we're gonna have this uh we will just
about but it might be out by this time
january our merch is coming out finally
and uh we we made uh hope we're making
two different bulk baseball caps like
model that to the old starter caps oh
cool you know like you would say like
new york and then knicks in that like
font yeah and it would be like orange
and blue or boston celtics we're doing
um
b-a-t-t-l-e and then buds in the script
on the thing uh
sorry t-a-s-t-e buds and then another
one
there was this we had a heated debate
about cookies versus cake cookies rice
ice cream nothing was ice cream
i was taking cookies and it was it was
one of those ones we were at each
other's throats and then all of a sudden
i just realized oh my god i didn't even
mention the girl scouts and i was like
the girl scouts i go that goddamn girl
scouts at the top of my like purple and
then those fans like to love that and
they picked over came a little bit of a
meme thing so we're also going to have
on top of that one of the star cats say
the god damn oh and then girl scouts and
script i mean like the old starter cap
oh that's funny
yeah
yeah so nice yeah
yeah i think i probably like ice cream
versus cookies i was like i mean is the
thing on hey babe that uh that that that
you and chris are kind of like
[Laughter]
because all the promo stuff for it is
like the two of you rolling around
shirtless or
or the two you like draped over each
other yeah we
yeah we we we we play fast and loose
with the right i see gay right there uh
gay babe oh that was for gay pride week
episode okay hey babe we renamed it i'm
cool if that is i i i i i i don't i
don't know that i know that yeah this is
funny because like on the impression
we're not gay but no i know we exhibit
all the traits of of of of gay men i
don't know
you were playing you were playing into
that angle no no no all advertising is
fugazi
oh the theme song is amazing casey wrote
it yeah you know this theme song now
casey did both teams
oh man oh cause i i i watched the clips
on uh on instagram is where i can see
you guys so can you play can we play the
each of the theme songs so casey did
both of these but but this isn't the
full theme song right you don't get all
the way on casey's
okay so let's just play the play the
regular theme song for him casey nailed
it for both of them casey is good at
this casey joe sterling
he also did what say use 100 yes
although that was an original song his
that we took that we loved yeah
how do we not have
i don't have ants i know
wow when you're working at home you
watch ads
i said give me give me a euro house my
inspiration to him was i'm too sexy my
right said fred
and he came back with that it was
awesome that's great which by the way
wasn't the original theme so you made
something that i really loved and then
people when we introduced casey's will
go back to the old one because they just
got used to it now
they don't even can't be casey yeah it's
so funny but even that has a very like
uh you know
yeah
yeah yeah we we like that you know
what's funny too is like because because
i remember like when the practical
joker's movie poster came out if you
look at it i looked at it and i saw joe
it looked to me i was like it looks like
joe was just plugging you in the ass
i looked at it for like a beat it was
like it was like five seconds and he
goes well that's all i'll ever see now
i actually i actually still really love
that movie poster yeah we we we asked
them to do we wanted to be like a
throwback like the 80s movies like the
european vacation like you know those
kind of
vacations
the structure of the film itself was fun
too did you guys have fun making the
movie we did we did we had not fun at
times but we had fun too it was
stressful we lived in atlanta for about
a month and a half or so and um we
didn't have any days off it was it was
fun movies so weird it's like 16 hours a
day and like half the day you're just
sitting there did you have shorter days
on tv like what's the big yeah
well when we first started our days were
like eight to ten hours then they went
down to like
eight hours
six to eight hours and now we have it
like
you're banging out four hours six six
hours four to six hours but then
sometimes we'll do two in a day to make
up for that right but you know usually
it's about six hours if the bit is
substantial and if it's a shorter bit
we'll do two or and then if it's a
punishment sometimes we could be out in
four hours which is a dream it's amazing
it's a dream
i would go uh they call us on the movie
at six in the morning i get up at five
in the morning take a shower get to
wardrobe put on all my wardrobe put on
all my makeup i had my hair a certain
way i had all these jewelry things fake
earrings all this stuff
put it all on then go sit in the trailer
have eggs
and then you just sit in this trailer
and they they give you the sides for the
day
and sometimes i waited six hours before
anyone came and got me yeah it's it's
it's and we were like can we can we just
assess this a little better because why
am i getting them at five o'clock when
i'm when i'm going to shoot at 3 p.m
there were days like that i think it's
par for the course because that's how it
is on all the other movies and shows
i've been on but yeah but maybe you know
that was maybe a really bad one but
other than that it was like it was kind
of wild that we were filming a movie
yeah the full freaking movie like it was
like it was just like wow acted
well i reacted that was my favorite part
we used to act in sketches all the time
it was like that but like it was cool
like and you know it was cool like paul
abdul being in scenes with us that was
cool you know or i forget who else was
in it but like i never really think
about the movie that much i i don't
either and they're weird like you never
never think about it you know it was
like you know what it is it was like it
was in theaters when the pandemic hit we
we were all going into our fifth week
when it got pulled so we're forever
cemented as
what was in the movie theater is when
everything shut down and like the
history was it was all a movie and uh
and a movie was a limited release on
like i think 100 screens something like
yeah like i don't even think it was i
don't know
and then if it did well it would expand
and it kept doing well
our fans man and word of mouth and so it
expanded from it doubled and it tripled
and then all of a sudden in like the
fourth week we won thousands of screens
and they weren't going to do that
because they don't want you don't they
don't want to just take that risk to put
it in that many screens and if people
don't go see it so like always you know
i like being on door but we have to
prove ourselves a little bit there we
didn't know we didn't know either though
and then the fans came out it grew it
grew it grew and then we cracked the top
ten yeah which i couldn't believe yeah i
couldn't believe and then and and we had
battles too because like the the staff
we had a different present network who
greenlit the movie was gone by the time
the movie came out they got replaced by
somebody else who didn't have ownership
of the movie so it was almost like an
afterthought for them and then warner
brothers this is not about that always
[ __ ] makes me [ __ ] super happy
even though we have a great relationship
with warner brothers but we asked warner
brothers because they own us like
through company one of media want to
media we were like we we figured it was
a home run for them to distribute the
movie warner brothers said no
we're like we're not gonna we don't know
one of us is we don't know how to market
small movies like this anymore it's what
they said to us so whatever we sell we
self-did a blah blah blah and then when
the numbers start coming in
we got our agents got a angry call from
warner brothers being like why didn't
you bring this to us this should have
been our movie this should have been
ours and and our agent goes it was the
best thing ever to be able to say to
them
we brought it to you guys you guys
turned it down and blah blah blah yeah
so gangster that's cool yeah but it was
like we had to grind like we would go we
all split up and we went on like for
like a week or two we would go
to theaters to host the movie we were
doing like five six theaters a day so we
just get in the thing go to movie time
then we tell everybody we're gonna be
there to drive sales and then we give an
intro do a little q a leave go to
another movie another movie number like
six seven a day for like two or three
weekends
that's great yeah well i mean i don't
know i just really don't know i i can't
quantify
what that did well theaters would
definitely cause what i said that car on
the poster i bought i own that that's in
my that's how my house that's not my
house that's in like a garage somewhere
near me right now and and i we spent
time i think you came for some of that
where where because i got really sick
remember i couldn't go away yeah the
second taught me yeah like no me and you
were in a car that we went in that car
johnson drove yeah jersey we drove down
south jersey and hit like seven or eight
movie theaters and we told people we let
people sit in the car and take pictures
of the cars yeah but we also flew like
we also flew all over the country yeah
that's you guys did that i got but i
really don't know i i couldn't tell you
there's no way to quantify that you've
proved yourself is there going to be
another movie or would you guys do a
real scripted movie that'd be cool yeah
i i
is us though no
i would do a scripted movie i don't know
if i'd be a joker's movie yeah we we got
to ask is
on the heels of this we got prompted to
do another one
and uh i think we didn't think we'd do
it right away and then i think the heat
for that has kind of died down and as is
the movie industry on a whole you know
but i mean it probably streams well
we would also change things you know we
learned a lot from doing it yeah and uh
we would we would need to have certain
control over certain things yeah that
was a bummer now the thing about the
movie is like as as wonderful as it is
and we made
lifelong friendships on it and um
there was so many positives about it and
it was just
just a really great personal achievement
for us for me whatever but uh it wasn't
uh how we make the show and it wasn't
the same exact crew as the show and we
didn't have the exact same control as
the show and there was just a lot of
factors and elements that play we
weren't and we weren't in new york and
uh you know it goes up the chain of
command and you know creative decisions
that we we didn't win every one of them
and uh so the movie didn't necessarily
net out to the exact movie we would have
made if we were left alone
and so you know when you watch them you
watch it afterwards that's what you
focus on yeah that's why i initially
said no they wanted to do second one
right away and i was like
yeah because it was like you guys didn't
give us like
what they should have done is given us
five million dollars and and said come
back to us for the movie do whatever you
want that's what they should have done i
don't understand if we because we're not
in we never made a movie so maybe they
could say there's no precedent for that
for us they don't know like it's always
prove it prove it for us prove it yeah
so i don't think they're gonna do that
without us proving it first i think
we've kind of proved it with this and
that's why i think we could have had
another one and maybe we could have set
our terms a little bit more but the
terms in getting this movie we had to
concede a bunch and so we did it we said
or we want to do this or not and we just
we were a little bit iffy and then we're
like let's just do it when are we
getting a chance to do this and so we
conceded a bunch of things yeah and
that's all it is i mean it's it's also
fine like it's fine with that came good
decisions too yeah like it's not like
everything that there's things in the
movie i absolutely love you know what i
mean i love it there's things i love
about these things i don't like about it
i think that's probably got to be the
same for everything any movie you know
it's all it's our baby so it's like hard
to like relinquish decisions we did but
um yeah i think the fans we did enough
for the fans the fans liked it thank you
so much [ __ ] in there that i love and
like you said the relate like the
director chris henshi he's the best he's
like he's such a good friend he's still
a friend dude i'd love to work with
hinchey again i would do that in a
heartbeat yeah yeah i mean he's he's our
boy i actually just saw him we saw him
hanging out with him
he came to the borgata show i swear i'd
love to watch you guys write a script a
comedy movie written by like
just not yourselves not the jokers yeah
yeah yeah we're working on stuff we have
the development deal uh that we're
working on and we're working on some
scripted stuff that is not us right now
we got a call about it and and but but
like but the best part to discuss you
know this is why like when you have
dinner you you have all these
discussions at the beginning of dinner
because you're eating the appetizers
like these fun conversations
not like at the end of the dinner not at
the end of the day when everybody just
wants to go the [ __ ] home wow
and everybody's worried about who's
paying the bill and like you know what i
mean like [ __ ] like that you know you
have these fun discussions at the
beginning for me for me for me hey taste
buddies have you guys checked out noon
yet noom n-o-o-m is basically an app
that you can get that helps you
to change your psychology about the way
you uh interact with food that's the
best way to do it it's not really a diet
it's more of a program instead of
setting like strict rules or whatever
it empowers you with practical knowledge
to build smarter more sustainable habits
that's what it's about it's not about a
diet change it's about a lifestyle
change and they know that everybody's
different and they believe in progress
not perfection so it's not one of those
things that hammers you if you do wrong
you're falling off the wagon they don't
believe that you know you could eat
anything that's uh that's something did
you know that when you when you do that
because chrissy uses it and he tells you
about it chris said the other day that
he got on the on the wagon again
um about being healthy and he said for
the last 10 days he's been strict uh and
he said he's he's he's been using newman
he said to me yesterday that he swears
because you said to him you look oh wow
you look a little bit better he's like
it's been 10 days only but he's been so
strict and he's been using this that he
says and he feels better and he feels
more mental clarity i know that sounds
like something that we would say for
this but that boy said that to me in my
foyer like two days ago no he needs the
direction he needs this right because
he's one of those guys that just goes
off one way or the other way so he gets
intense this is why this is good for him
and he follows it he follows you know
and then and then it works for him and
then he'll just go eat like he'll eat
like a whole hot dog
uh they won't tell you what you can eat
so they don't believe in good or bad
foods they just give you the knowledge
to make your informed choices to fit the
lifestyle for you an off day is okay it
won't set you off course they just get
you back on track it's 10 minutes a day
and they just teach about eating habits
the stats they have showed me are that
more than 75 percent of users complete
the program more than 60 of the users
lose 5 or more body weight within 4
months 16 weeks and more than 60 of the
users engage with the program and they
keep the weight off for a year or more
that's their stats pretty cool uh
let's see
let's see what goals are you working
toward right now all right what do you
want what do you want to work toward
with it doom can help you you can share
uh
for me like it's because it for me it's
not just about losing weight it's about
having more energy so that was a big
thing for me because like i'm still
sluggish all the time so this actually
helps you getting more energy and that's
what chris said to me yesterday too um
you don't need rules to lose weight okay
just the knowledge and wisdom to empower
you to build more sustainable habits
uh with newm taking care of your health
is empowering instead of stress inducing
no need for fear of ruining the whole
program with an off day like we said
it'll get you right back on track 10
minutes a day guys no grueling
workouts in the morning and no big
chunks out of your day start building
better habits for healthier long-term
results sign up for your trial at noom
start building better habits for
healthier long-term results sign up for
your trial at noom.com tastebud
no s leave off the less ass for savings
sign up for your free trial at noom.com
tastebud that's n o o m dot com slash
taste bud n o
m
slash taste bud
butcher box butcher box butcher box say
it three times in the mirror and you get
your meat
you get 14 pounds of meat delivered to
your door it's very much like candy man
uh i love butcher box uh i don't like
going out in public and i really
actually don't know how to choose good
meat because i'm not really the best
cook so meal prepping is usually
difficult for me but butcher box makes
it easy uh it's a subscription service
it takes the guesswork out of finding me
you don't have to go there and talk to
somebody about the mean you don't have
to poke at the meat you have to wonder
if that blood seeping out of the package
is like gonna kill you uh butcher box
sources that mean from partners with the
highest quality and standards so they're
taking all that work for you no more
searching the grocery store they have
100 grass-fed beef free-range organic
chicken wild cards seafood much more
uh
my favorite from them is is the seafood
because i'm trying a little healthier
right now uh their sourcing decisions
are made holistically keeping the farmer
the planet and the animal and all that
in mind um yeah so let me know uh you
know if you guys like it me and christy
have been using it it's nuts because
they send up to each boxing container to
eight to 14 pounds of meat which sounds
like a lot but you do go through it you
really do especially if you start
cooking more if you start cooking a
couple times a week you'd be surprised
how fast it goes um it's enough for 24
meals what they sent there's no
antibiotics no hormones they ship all
over the continent of the united states
packed fresh ship frozen for convenience
you customize what you want or you could
pick from pre-selected boxes for a
limited time butcher box is offering new
members
for a limited time butcher box is
offering new members a great deal for
new year
sign up and at butcherbox.com taste buds
and you'll receive the ultimate new
year's bundle in your first box this
deal includes ground beef chicken thighs
and pork butt that's more than seven
pounds of meat added to your first box
for free get this new year's bundle
before it's gone by going to
butcherbox.com
slash taste buds for me
for me
first of all a few things appetizers
you're flying too close to the sun you
please yeah
most of the time if you're like me and
you sit down when you're ready to eat
your ravenous you ever have a taquito
i have love a taquito right you don't
have that dessert taquitos no but here's
what i can do yeah i can say you know
what i like taquitos but instead of
giving me four yeah give me eight i'll
have the taquitos for my main and all of
a sudden any appetizer i want can become
my main i just double the plate size
so i don't have to lose out on the app
i don't i don't lose out on traditional
i don't lose out i'm talking about i
don't you lose out on the app no i don't
you just subtracted you didn't add well
no i don't lose out on a traditional
food that could be an app i could always
make an app my main right but why would
you do that like
you're talking potato skins
yes i could just be like never mind
sharing the skins i'll take i'll take it
all to myself it hasn't how does it mean
and i can still eat the potatoes i don't
lose out because i can't eat apple pie
for dinner it doesn't mean anything no
you can't though
no you can't eat dinner that's not
that's not what are you talking about
i'm still eating regular food
i can transfer an appetizer to a maine
and it'll be wonderful to do that you
can't eat it
but then it's not an appetizer by the
way but then it's amazing well here's
the thing i think people fly too close
to someone appetizers i think what does
that mean i think everyone's explaining
that to everybody i think i think
everyone gets screwed without greek
mythology because appetizers are
appetizers they come they main all the
time
you don't even believe what you're
saying i don't believe what you're
saying
he's bullshitting he doesn't even
believe
i love going to really nice restaurants
i go to my favorite restaurants all the
time and i say i got to try a sampling
of everything and i always order
appetizers and every time it happened to
us in quality italian recently every
single time i go all these apps these
apps these apps and then the most
expensive part the main comes out and
i'm like oh i am so full right now and i
take a few bites to my main and i take
it home and the main is probably a
wonderful dish that i don't get to enjoy
because i'm too full from the apps the
appetizers your appetite
you have an appetite
you have an appetite and you have to eat
dinner and then they're like before we
can get you it's just a scam from
restaurants like i could go order my
food and eat my food why am i ordering
gaffiness a bit oh that's the food we
have before we have our food like
imagine telling that to countries like
oh no you talk about dessert that's what
we have after we have our food yeah like
you could just go sit down and i i have
a pork shop and i went to dinner right
but now they're it's all marketing
they're like before your pork chop you
have an appetite we'll tease why do you
tease your ass you're an adult you can
make a decision well that's why i'm
saying i don't i i would say if i choose
let me ask you a question that night
that night a quality italian that you're
talking about we we did overdo the apps
that's for sure yeah how was the dessert
we couldn't get it then we had to run oh
that's right that's because dessert's
the most disposable part of the food
because if you have to lop off a part of
the meal to get to your show
or in this case the ghostbusters
premiere i'll tell you what's the
expendable one no the dessert not true
because honestly if i knew i had limited
time to begin with and i didn't think
i'd make it there would be a frank
conversation with me and my participants
at the table is do we want to do apps or
do we want to do dessert yeah if we
don't only have enough time let's get
that main and get that dessert in there
dessert is a beautiful curveball that
sends you on your way um dessert is like
your dessert is like you're shoving on
top of everything it's disgusting the
dessert you're getting a dish coming
from a completely different chef it's a
different person you're getting their
creation and their expertise whereas the
same person who cooked the app is
cooking the main what's what the hell
does that have to do with anything
because i don't care i just think that
you're getting more of a breath of
people's
professions
by the time a pastor is not a regular
chef appetizers are um
just a [ __ ] gift i would never i
think you actually said it best when you
were like you wouldn't make dessert a
main meal but appetizers every one of
them is so delicious that they in of
themselves could be the main meal but
the beauty of it is you can have
more than just the main deal
it's not just is you can have steak and
the potatoes that's a very glutenous way
of thinking though that's welcome to the
usa that's why i understand that how is
that going
we have an epidemic of of of obesity in
this country i'm on i'm i'm in that i'm
in that bucket probably and it's all
good
[Laughter]
but it's extra food it's just more more
food of the food you're already getting
where the dessert is not more of what
you're getting it's a departure from
what you're getting first of all you
roll in you're [ __ ] hungry you're
gonna order food that food's gonna take
time to make but those taquitos are
coming out in 15 minutes
that's a scam that's the problem
that's a ruse that's otherwise your
dinner's over too fast no no no no so
now you're ordering extra buckets and
plates of food so you can again where
are you going will you like get me a
bucket of taquitos yeah to send the
experience like sit down and be like all
right well dinner all right thank you
i'm very hungry i i will take the steak
i like my medium well it takes a little
more time to make because you may bring
out the taquitos beforehand
i mean you're really held bent on these
taquitos i mean now the people i don't
see i don't i don't normally see
taquitos on a menu i really don't i like
them i love taquitos
but here's the thing i can but i could
have taquitos any time i could have them
for the maine you don't have ice cream
in your freezer right now i do so you
could i have jenny's ice cream shout out
to jenny's great work jenny you're gonna
have it any time you want as well no but
what i'm saying is you the reason you
can't eat the dessert for the maine is
because it's not nutritionally
sustainable
it's a treat it's a send-off at the end
you couldn't have dessert for dinner
every night you would die right okay
let's not get it twisted dessert is
sugar sugar is poison i get it all right
but it's it's it's it's it's it's in
moderation it's okay
your whole premise about what you're
about to say is is predicated on me
accepting that appetizers are just small
versions of the meal i don't feel like
that's what they are
but all i'm saying is a lot of times we
get the apps the apps are great they
satiate you and then they ruin the main
course and the main course is really
supposed to be the star of the show it's
supposed to be the best dish it's
supposed to be the signature you know
dish that you're getting it's just a
steak a little bit of self-control
everything
can be okay you don't have to eat all
the taquitos i know but you do we you do
you
say you don't eat all this how many
people are you having dinner with it's
like if it's do you want okay but i've
i'm not saying i don't do it i've done
it i'm speaking from experience i've
eaten alone and ordered an appetizer
i've eaten with two people in order for
appetizers okay i've eaten with a huge
table of people ordered a huge bunch of
apps what do you have against appetizers
if i'm putting them against dessert i
pick dessert because dessert appetizer
is just more of a let's let's say you're
having a hot savory dish for dinner it's
repetitive because the appetizers are
also that so
with chips your main becomes more of the
same
it could be it could be it could be
spinach chip with chips
that is a salty savory type of thing
delightful it is by the time dessert
comes i all i want to do is get away
from these people well
by the time okay well by the time the
main comes i'm full from the app uh
here's what i'll tell you
that's not true no one needs half no one
needs half the apps you're talking about
a waiter comes over you finish you're
enjoying the app there's half left he
goes to take it you don't go
you don't know i don't perform assault i
i if anything it's like hey wrap those
quesadillas up i'll take them home all
right but i you and you're not wrapping
any dessert you end up wrapping the mane
that's true
nobody takes home this
nobody wrap wraps dessert you you you
take the spoon and you get every last
piece of dessert
nobody walks away with dessert on the
plate people are people you know what
they say
here's the app you know what you know
what this is saying you ever heard of it
you have room for dessert this is the
way it says it you know why he says that
because the abs
yeah that's why you have room for the
reason he's because of that
the reason he's asking that is because
his check is based on a percentage of
the tip the tip is based on the tip is
based on a percentage check he knows if
he could sell you a [ __ ] 15 slice of
ice cream
scoop of ice cream he he's getting 1.50
what about the people that are like that
you're getting run by a scam no no no
you're getting scared the reason he has
to prompt you to see if you're okay for
the intake is because you overloaded at
the top so you think he doesn't ask
people that question
if you don't order appetizers he just
assumes you're having sometimes
no well then then he's going to ask you
so he's asking you in both cases yeah
but it really is because of the app a
lot of you have never been a waiter in
your life a lot of times i did i went
where did you where you were
but i waited at the bar okay but
so
uh do you have room for dessert
sometimes i don't like something
sometimes they say at the top
are you leaving room for dessert are you
they even predicated you guys leaving
room for dessert it is it is so sad to
see my friend
become such a sucker for the upsell
you used to be savvy man and like now
you just suck he's pre-selling you
dessert he's already your check is he's
chess he's he's up in that bill left and
all right anything to drink would you
like some coffee to change i know james
itching no but the reason that they
throw you a [ __ ] mint the reason the
question is delicious
the reason the question isn't are you
having dessert and do you have room for
dessert is because we stuffed our faces
starting with four apps before the main
that's what it is i'll tell you what
right now i like apps i'm making an
argument against the theory of them
because i'll tell you right now cut out
domain i could go from apps to dessert
i can go over apps to dessert but then
you're cutting out the main i can't do
app's main dessert can't i've seen you
do i mean i do do it but if i had to
choose i would cut out the app not to
deserve okay well i think that's i've
taken apps home i've sent i've
you that's another thing for apps you
can take app home and have them at two
in the morning that's fine but you can't
do that with ice cream you
well ice cream maybe
you can't do it with it but every other
dessert what other dessert apple pie
alamo do you bring that home every
single dessert pie cake cookies you you
eat half a half a piece of cake you're
like wrap that up and take that home
oh yeah but no but you don't though
because nobody needs to have a piece of
cake what are you a psychopath in social
media
nobody eats half a piece of cake you
make these things up and then you try to
hold me to them i don't agree with you
that people don't leave cake behind when
they're done at the table they
show me the person that doesn't eat that
cake podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
they are one of our biggest most
recurring sponsors and uh let's talk
about them is there something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
that rings true for most of us uh there
is for me uh
i have a lot of [ __ ] weighing on me that
i'm not gonna get into now but we all
need an outlet people better help assess
your needs and matches you with a
licensed professional therapist in under
48 hours it could happen it's not a
crisis line it's just professional
counseling it's all done online it's all
secure and they have experts from all
over that you may not be able to have
access to if you just went to somebody
in your area it's clients worldwide they
are upping um all of their uh therapists
uh because it has become so popular um
you can go on their website
betterhelp.com go to slash tastebuds uh
and join over a million people who have
taken charge of their mental health
that's better help
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash taste buds
so many people are doing it i said they
are recruiting additional accounts
there's a special offer for you guys our
facebook listeners is 10 off your first
month at betterhelp.com tastebuds and of
course we have a special offer for you
guys for our taste buds listeners our
buddies you'll get 10 off your first
month so go do it now check it out can't
hurt it is betterhelp.com taste buds
pimp you're pro you're pro at everything
you do oh yeah you're a videographer
editor photographer and
do you
love canva pro or what i love them it
helps me edit this show actually think
about the world of difference before
there was something like this available
to you to now and and because you could
speak to it even more than i can because
you are in there in the trenches and you
you work on this podcast and you work on
a lot of media right online media
incredible resource you have video photo
templates all this different type of
stuff you just click through it all in
one source canva pro is a design
platform that empowers you to create and
share stunning content with just a few
clicks designing with them is fast it's
fun you can choose from thousands of
templates like like pimp said they're
all ready to customize and just or to
start from scratch uh they have fonts
photos videos and more that add
personality and edge to whatever you're
designing
they have an extensive library of tools
uh you don't have to go searching on the
internet it really makes it easy it's
all right there designing has never been
easier sharing editing and commenting in
real time helps you stay organized and
on the same page on top of team projects
projects no more misplaced files or
tedious back and forth because you can
house everything right there plus you
and four teammates can unlock everything
camera pro has to offer for just 12.99 a
month that is
pretty damn good deal if you're working
on a project of for all that provides
with five different people uh their
content planner you'll save time
planning creating and posting social
media uh design like a pro with canva
pro right now you can get a free 45-day
extended trial when you use our promo
code design like a pro with canva pro
right now guys you can get a free 45-day
extended trial when you use our promo
code just go to canva.me
slash tastebuds to get your free 45-day
extended trial that's c-a-n-v-a
dot m-e-canva dot me slash taste buds
canva dot me slash taste buds coming to
the mic
look
i've even done this with apps tell me
i've done this it's not even like uh
wrap the app up i'll take it home there
were times where i go they go you want
to rap that i go
yeah
and i and i let them take the app that i
paid for back i don't know why you would
do that that's on youtube because i've
had enough if you go to your wasteful if
you order apps and eat half it's
wasteful
how we're trained clean your plate
and what are you what's about wasteful
how about this how about y'all take an
orange sorbet yeah and it [ __ ] rolls
up in a in a [ __ ]
that orange we're throwing that in the
garbage you want to talk about people in
other countries all right we're throwing
[ __ ] right like you don't you don't
the segments from those things are going
into a beautiful salad but it doesn't
matter that it's a whole orange wasted
gone done
for fancy sorbet that's [ __ ] man and
that's pretentious as [ __ ] just give it
to me in a bowl
yeah well it's about the experience the
dining experience it's a sensory
experience
okay why what are the advantages of
eating an appetizer
yeah
where the latest scientific research has
shown that eating appetizers before
meals helps to lose weight and lose more
calories because eating appetizers
abundantly fools the centers of
satiation
satiety in the stomach and prepares for
the feeling of rapid fullness because it
is known scientifically that the nerves
are blah blah blah blah blah that is i
don't know where you google that from
that is such [ __ ] because what
people do
through it that's the first this isn't
so [ __ ] this isn't some conspiracy
website that's the first thing that
comes up on google that was my opinion
my opening was that appetizers
and they're telling you that that that
okay great they're so great so great an
upside is that i i i eat less calories
because like are you out of your mind i
can't eat my pork chop now stuff so now
that's so i lose those clams
or appetizers right that's gonna fill
your stomach to have two or three
stuffed clams no
but but i'm talking about
the the appetizer the broad sense of an
appetizer yeah you can go in there and
go light on an appetizer and just stuff
clams of course sure but you're not
gonna eat stuffed clams all the time
other times you're gonna get some
bangers in there you're gonna get some
big big big name stuff but what's a
banger what depends on the type of
restaurant are we at a local bar and
grill oh we had a pizzeria or yeah we
had a five-star restaurant's choice
think about all the apps that came out
at the italian places you went to i
can't recall them all but they were
freaking out
come on man like we ordered all those
apps but i can't have to live like that
i think absolutely you could just order
like a nice app but this is not the way
people are trained we are trained to
order a bunch of apps and then be full
for the main and they call it saving
calories but what it is is you're being
wasteful both to your wallet
and to the into the earth i don't know
if overpaying for frozen milk is the way
to go you know in terms of saving money
but how are you at the end of the meal
there's nothing more i want to do than
just go home
go home and you assault me with these
desserts wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait we're like suddenly
like it's another weight and then
people's [ __ ] spoons are going oh
that looks good and like dessert
goes out the [ __ ] window
that's all right i can pick up like this
oh you're biting a chip and you're
putting it right back in the table who
does that nobody's doing that in my
watch people watch people do it
it's more acceptable dessert's more of a
community thing and uh you know what i
don't want to say that i don't agree
with that i think they're neck and neck
but i think the dessert
is messier than the appetizer let me
issue this yeah why when the dessert
comes you're claiming all i want to do
is go home
but you gave the appetizer a pat on the
back for extending the meal yeah the
best part of the meal you get
everybody's excited to see each other
you're a little peckish but you want to
focus on the moment be
because mains take time to create
appetizers are meant to be quick
and out of the table as soon as possible
okay that theory is decent yeah
so
you know it removes the peckishness
makes you enjoy it everybody's most
excited overall but what i'm saying is
if you're going to a place and i go to
you tonight yeah you have a wonderful
mane and a dessert well apps in a main
and no dessert well you know i'm doing
that never mind because you don't like
sweets though i look i i can enjoy these
things i i just i think that they're
their own thing but but either way the
meal is the same length okay if you get
apps in a main it's 45 minutes if you
get a main and it's going to tell you
what i'm saying i'll tell you why
because let's say i just had a steak
yeah
i'm ready to go that's when i i'm not
going home because of time i'm going
home because i got a nice steak in my
stomach i'm ready to get i'm ready to
get a sweet
yeah salty sweet okay but i think like
well that's fine but like i'm just
telling you why i'm just like i'm done
like i don't need the i don't need the
the guy coming trying to bull me to
getting a sorbet and then and then and
then they they're like well here what
sorbet
we got a [ __ ] a melon sorbet they
might as well play
one over the [ __ ] thing yeah but
that's the [ __ ] but there's so much
tiramisu what the [ __ ] is a tiramisu go
to peppalino's get yourself a cheesecake
forget about it
your balls will blow off yeah but the
cheesecake really kind of got co-opted
into the whole thing a cheesecake for
going to someone's house hey i came over
here guys i like cheesecakes let's tell
them they're on the menu in restaurants
since the dawn of time yeah but that's
not their main focus their own focus is
is is to bring to people what all you oh
yeah what if your father died i brought
a cheesecake what about that's a isn't
that a fruitcake it's all sorts of cakes
okay my point being what about what
about co-op desserts desserts can be
very very delicate and dainty and petite
desserts
at fine dining establishments a lot of
times they come out they're works of art
like what and and they're only a few
spoonfuls i i have stuff like that all
the time like what just anything in that
version no but it is hard to like you
know they'll they'll they'll have like a
you know it'll just be a small portion
dessert where you get the you get the
benefit of the dessert but you're not
overloading and that's you let me ask
you something just so i understand where
you're coming from do you prefer that or
do you prefer like your average hearty
dessert and i don't mean that as an
insult no i prefer either you know
either whatever this is i i like i like
the ceremony of dessert i like the fact
that like so when when you go to a meal
it's a sensory experience you want to go
through life without jalapeno papas
no i'll just have them as my main if i
have to choose if i have so now you
don't want steak if i have to
if i have to choose
like if i'm going to go watch the game
downstairs i'll make a box of jalapeno
poppers yeah i'll top it off with a
cookie
i don't need a hamburger in the middle
but i don't make myself three course
meals at home either though i don't care
what i'm saying is that i could always
have my app as my main if i so choose
people like crab cake i go make that a
main they put two crab cakes on it now
all of a sudden i got two crab cakes i
mean the same thing that you ate for the
appetizer for my mane i understand your
theory i'm just saying
in our long friendship i don't think
i've ever heard you say that i don't
think i've ever heard you say double up
the crab cakes that'll be my main we
have what are you talking about
sit down and you order [ __ ] 50 things
he does that and then the two you start
trading off he does that you no you just
do split skis with them yeah but right
but i'm saying i like advertising can't
because you only work with two yeah it
happens all the time yeah i listen to me
you guys okay let's take going out to
eat or eating in general eating in
general is for sustenance but also it
has become
a very like i said it's a very sensory
social experience so for to awaken my
senses i'd rather have
both ends of the coin i'd rather have a
savory
food and i'd i'd like to have the
experience of the flip side of that coin
with sweet if i'm not having the dessert
i'm having just more of the same side of
the coins you want to walk into a
restaurant sit down and be like i will
have a steak
and then that's it
and then you're just sitting there for
the 40 minutes of the story oh it
decides that good sides
well but that's what i'm saying like you
give me get a steak a baked potato and
maybe a green some broccoli with salad
salad yes oh well that's i don't think
salad counts as an appetizer okay i
don't oh well i appreciate that yeah and
i will say that a salad is a really nice
starter it's good for digestion it is
usually light enough
and you've and it can it's easy to not
make it healthy but it can be healthy
yeah and then you're getting a little
diversity
yeah and it's uh you know you're still
getting that time in there you're
getting a good 20 minutes i don't know
though if i'm if i might say a chili's
that i would want to their starter salad
over jalapeno poppers or a [ __ ]
blooming onion i understand but then at
the end you don't want a brownie a la
mode at the end
if i never had a ground another brand of
the rest of my life i would be fine with
it
that is a personal choice so that's not
her convention yeah brownies are
people's like brownies forget about it i
saw someone get shot for a break i i
can't i see it's funny because like i
think that it's easier for me to obtain
in my personal life a cheesecake a scoop
of ice cream sorbet i think those are
easy to get
i what the [ __ ] am i gonna get a
jalapeno popper from i'm not making a
case of six babe it's just in the frozen
foods yeah you're not dicing one up at
home i get that yeah that's what i mean
like i these things like i should tell
you i love appetizers yeah of course but
you're an adult in this in this instance
you're just saying if you had to cut one
off you would you gotta go dessert i
don't think you did it it's the yin yang
it's a sea salt i think you got big eyes
right now i think that you are you love
dessert and you can't imagine your life
without it but i think in theory if you
tried to go without appetizers you
wouldn't make it
wow i don't think i would die i don't
know if you die but i think you'd be
happy man it's like you would look at
that menu remember you're ordering
advertisers when you're hungry and and
the menu is a female i'm starving by the
way i'm starving right now
you know what i mean like like
so many apps
dude let me ask you this do you order
dessert when you order the meal or do
you wait till the meals over and then
and then look at the dessert that one
you like that one i've never done what
you just said the first time have you
no but i don't really order dessert but
who does people do people sit down and
be like
this this is a dessert of that yeah but
that's what i mean if you're not the
person that's like i'm saving room for
ice cream like to me the menu you crack
it open you get that excitement i'm
hungry oh the taquitos yeah we're gonna
start with that oh this is actually this
is actually probably something
i think that this is skewed and weighted
in your direction because it's
psychological and actually because when
you arrive at the restaurant the
appetizers are the first thing you get
to eat you shouldn't get hungry so they
register in europe that's part of why
they're great but no no no no because
the first thing you eat no matter what
will make you feel that way but that
doesn't mean anything if you if you went
in that just means it's great if you
went in and ordered a burger you're
telling me the reason it's great but if
you went in and ordered the burger yeah
nothing prior to the burger yeah when
they bring the burger over you're you
have the excitement that you would have
for the app but apps we are
psychologically trained to think that
they're the thing that we most
anticipate because they come out first
and we're hungry
fast and first they come out first
because we make them come out first if
the if the main came out first i would
feel the same about the idea is that the
main should take longer to prepare right
that's why appetizers exist that's why
you get so excited it's a money grab
and that's how i feel about desserts
that's another right well that's another
reason you don't like dessert it comes
at the end and you're too full but if
you didn't eat the apps you could have a
new relationship with a dessert no no no
yes it would flourish your relationship
no because i could ha i could just have
because it's enough for me to be full
with without the abs if i just have a
steak half a baked potato and broccoli
like i'm full already that's nice but
you know how you said if i went without
apps forever i wouldn't make it yeah
like if you just did that forever and
never gave yourself a dessert you'd be
able to deal with that
yeah because i don't think i'm addicted
to sugar maybe then you might be i also
don't i i i i don't like sweets i'm not
a cookies i don't like cookies you and
gada are all about cooking cookies yeah
all that [ __ ] like it wouldn't it would
never occur to me to have really sweets
in general isn't my thing all right you
know
so i i don't know but i do feel you're
gonna take a drumming on this i i i i i
think most people see i know people
people love apps and especially i think
that people in this day and age are
skewed to more healthy habits and even
though apps are not i feel like
uh people are going to just lop in
dessert with an unhealthy habit you get
thai like tight i i'll go to the lettuce
wraps
you're talking cheesecake factory to me
yeah guess what you're talking the
cheesecake
factory yeah
you brought up a place that's predicated
on dessert and even they know that they
can't go at it without appetizers
think about that
they have five pages
you brought up though the cheesecake
factory what a perfect
scent yeah you already know my argument
i've already said to you that i don't
feel that i feel that cheesecakes were
co-after as a dessert they were family
visiting either babe the factory
they say they lure you in yeah with the
with the promise of cheesecake
and everything else is an afterthought
cheesecake is great ice creams are great
all this is great the reason you're
forcing them into dessert rolls
what they're by definition dessert no
absolutely not ice cream is not by
definition of dessert i mean when you
were a kid in the ice cream truck came
by you were like i gotta run inside eat
dinner real quick then go out and get an
ice cream or you're like [ __ ] you get me
a car but dessert doesn't only have to
come after a meal that's another
beautiful thing an appetizer by
definition has to come before something
else you eat a dessert a dessert
whenever you have no no no no dessert is
part of the meal
of course
when you go grab an ice cream from an
ice cream check what are you doing what
are you having i have ice cream
i mean i have ice cream how would you
categorize the ice cream uh uh a summery
treat
a [ __ ] treat is a dessert look can
you look up the definitions
i'm having a treat no but i wouldn't sit
there and be like i'm having an
appetizer if i'm not eating something
after it i'm having jalapeno poppers
you're talking about the conventions of
a meal okay so you're saying if you have
a jalapeno poppers alone they're not
exactly they're not appetizing because
they didn't come before them correct
we're talking about the structure of a
meal okay
usually full definition of dessert a
usually sweet course or dish
usually served at the end of a meal a
fresh fruit served after a sweet course
where okay all right yeah okay i'm not
arguing against i don't want to abolish
ice cream but let's just get back to the
cheesecake for a hot shot sure
their business model is predicated on we
are we are a factory for dessert
no for cheesecake for cheesecakes
they're not saying the dessert factory
but you go there and you eat the
cheesecake after the meal no you don't
you've never gone to the place gotten a
cheesecake and then gone to someone's
house with it
yeah but i'm just saying the cheesecake
factory they're luring people in
cheesecake with the promise of dessert
they're like we do dessert
they're calling a [ __ ] factory for
dessert no they're calling it a factory
but cheesecake you're right this is a
difference but cheesecake is dessert in
that no look
then why do they serve regular food if
it's a cheesecake factory you'd go in
and they just sell cheesecakes the
reason they sell food is because
cheesecake is meant to be the dessert
after the food
what do you think they got a bar and
alcohol there too like what are you
talking about right and if it was if
cheesecake was meant to be cheesecake
and that dessert in that establishment
he would just sell cheesecakes
by your own definition no no no you talk
about the title of a business
i have gone the cheesecake character
walked and bought a cheesecake and
walked out and got it for someone i i've
done that okay so where would i go butt
the cheesecake factory for such an item
any bakery or shoe or market
but i can go to the cheesecake factory
because that's what they're making them
but that's a restaurant
also but it's not just a restaurant it's
also a bakery
can you look it up and can you look it
up and see if cheesecake factory labels
themselves as a bakery
because i bet you they do
shadow cheesecake factory if you're
listening and we know that you are uh
is a global brand now they call them
dedicated to creating premium indulgent
cheesecakes their website is the
cheesecake factory factorybakery.com
they're a bakery
right but they are they're a bakery are
you going to sit here i will say you're
in a city and have the i have the stones
to tell me the cheesecake factory is not
a restaurant no i they are also a
restaurant what are they first
a factory
a factory cheesecake factory clearly has
identities yeah but you you're also
getting caught up man uh this is what
i'm talking about man so when you when
you drive to the mall
you're a sucker for the upsell and now
you're a sucker from advertising the
magic kingdom isn't really magic
you know that right it's it it's just an
oranges i don't understand it they're
the cheesecake factory but it doesn't
say bakery it doesn't say that this is
the website though this is because you
know why of the business yeah because
they're tapping in here to sell their
goods because they also sell their goods
in stores now so this is like a business
model for online that's frozen goods
that's what they
online revenue stream is packaged
all
push
they're
desserts that's why when you go to that
that's at the forefront they're not
going to sell you a thai lettuce wrap on
cheesecake factorybakery.com
but when you go to the mall it doesn't
say on the signage cheesecake factory
bakery because that is a restaurant and
they are luring you into that restaurant
with the promise of their delectables of
a cheesecake yeah yeah that's going to
come at the end of your meal which by
definition is different or you can walk
in and just buy one and walk away with
it which i've done i greeted this well
what do you disagreeing with me about
that i've gone into it i just imagine i
think it's a great point that that
i think it gives great weight to the
dessert that the one of the most famous
chains in in the world sure predicates
themselves on the basis of and what are
they what do they do there do they do
they do they have enough faith in the
dessert to make a dessert restaurant or
they're like [ __ ] man if we don't put
appetizers on this menu we're going out
of business toot sweet
toot sweet no there's [ __ ] more pages
of appetizers and then there are
desserts they're brick and mortar how
much what about their brick-and-mortar
business model is based on the
restaurant food yes and their online
business model is based on their
signature
desserts okay but by nature yeah the
cheesecake being housed in the
brick-and-mortar restaurant yeah that is
there
as for dessert okay
and and they're basing their whole
image on dessert okay you don't it's not
called the thai lettuce wraps factory no
of course not it's called the cheesecake
but they couldn't but it wouldn't be the
cheesecake factory would have to tie
lettuce wraps
if jesus factory does not send me
two two of everything on their 40-page
match you're gonna have an issue why
would they send it to you you're
mischaracterizing their business i am
not you you're twisting their great
vision for your own designs
all right i'll tell you what cheesecake
factory if you're listening and watching
send the free goods to whoever
categorized you the best all right we'll
let cheesecake factory decide we'll let
the factory workers
decide
i i don't i don't even have a a [ __ ]
dog in this fight i don't care if i get
anything from you guys no no i'm just
saying i brought i brought it up
and i'm an avowed customer
i'm the one who said that i came to your
place just to get the cheesecake
all right let's go to the phones let's
go to the phone there's no way you're
gonna this is a this is a tough one man
i don't know i feel like this tweet kind
of agrees with you here app is a pretend
meal dessert is the paycheck you get for
getting through dinner okay appetizers
are great in theory let's call up a
little pimpy unless you're a plate of
nachos
deep oh unless your plated nachos deep
knowing you have a whole entree oh
nachos are appetizer man come on
okay come on we didn't pick a winner
last time that's all right that's
delicious a good dessert beats a good
appetizer any day but appetizers have
better range can be anything from a
basket of mozzarella sticks to a fancier
dish plus you can sub an app for a meal
when you're not too hungry see they're
trying to use that i'm using that
against them they're using it as a yeah
they're using it as like a versatility
appetizer all the way plus when i was
fat ordering a piece of chocolate cake
after a whole meal just seemed like oh
dessert does put your abs put you in a
less judgy spot than desserts that's
just semantics though because you're
ordering the food the front loading
instead of back loading the best dessert
is better than the best watches you
shove your [ __ ] face and then you're
also ordering a sundae
the best dessert is better than the best
appetizer but appetizers are better
overall people are really not we're not
getting a lot of smarmy sarcastic jokey
responses in these last two apps we are
getting a lot of really
opinionated thought i always think i
want an appetizer but then i'm too full
at the end of the meal for dessert and i
get fomo
this is this is a popular opinion it is
but i just wish that people would
practice something i like to call
self-control
like you don't have to eat the whole
[ __ ] taquito plate appetizers are
lying to yourself that you're not eating
an extra meal desserts are honest and
they're for you at your worst
i love it that's that's
a winner for me that's uh austin uh at
aka canada 2016. well i just had a steak
let me throw down a [ __ ] a pile of
like fudge sundae it sounds disgusting
let's get let's get some app love in
there let's get a couple more uploads
yeah
dessert is stressed spelled backwards
which is exactly how people that choose
appetizers make me feel
was that a riddle i don't know
no
yeah
yeah he's saying that people that would
choose appetizers is backwards apps are
something a little special you're not
likely having apps at home before dinner
which was one of my but you sure [ __ ]
might have dessert plus apps are usually
the deep fried more taboo delicious
treat i'm not frying up some pickles
mozzarella sticks or taquitos like
something that's what i was saying
before man like i'll always have i'll
always have the ability to forge some
sort of dessert-like meal i'm not always
able to get the type of appetizers that
i want plus really if you look at it
and i you know don't get insulted by
this but like
like desserts is really like it's all
kind of like not saying that there's not
room for artistry in it okay there is a
hundred percent but it's all kind of a
lane
whose appetizers really would if i got a
mess
chef in this room if i go to where we
get slap silly my friend
that's fine depend on what you look like
i'd be fine with it listen
you see before yeah i know but i changed
it yeah
but like no no like like if i go to a
mexican restaurant the apps are
different than if i go to an italian
restaurant okay okay like the variety of
them is a little bit more whereas
dessert you're always ending up with
something cold something sweet
okay okay that's not a bad that's not a
bad thing
yeah we're on a refresh pimp we're still
at 56 i'm shadow band
i'm most certainly shadow band yeah
yeah i tweeted you get out of shadow i
tweeted that two hours ago it would
normally have about forty thousand votes
we have six thousand votes right now
just under but how do you i don't know
how do you get out of the shadow
unless it's the new this new polling
system because usually when you hit
polls yeah you have to write in the body
of the of the voting you have certain
amount of characters to write what you
want to write okay this this i don't
know where they must have an update and
the poll now is just the body of the
regular text so you can write a full
text a full tweet with the pole at the
bottom maybe they change the algorithm
and it's not getting as much love or i
don't know i don't know what it's maybe
because i maybe because i put an at tag
in the in the thing that could be that's
probably it it's probably they do that
whenever they think you're promoting
something
they're real sly [ __ ] silly because
they're not what this jacket is for fix
it jack jacks
five fifty six hundred people yeah still
a good i would say i think you're gonna
get trounced here all right drum roll
advertise is really all better humble
pie drum roll i know i know i know i
would agree i think you might have won
this uh
humble pie pimpy give it to me pimp it
app
all right i mean q b q takes a w
split
and it's pretty handily uh appetizers
have won 63.2
to desserts 36.8
i thought it would be even closer than
that that is a tough loss so man
desserts are so i don't know but people
there's something called a sweet tooth
people don't tell me they have a savory
tooth
no i guess not but at the same point
everybody loves appetizers
[ __ ] nobody doesn't order apps
everybody want his i know people are in
love with apps and i think the reason
that i went down in flames is because
apps come first and people
psychologically associate
uh them being
satiated and and and by the end it might
you might have gotten failed by this
because i think apps are like just an
accepted part of dinner
right i deserve an opt-in dessert it's
an opt-in it's a special treat it's
viewed as it is wild though that
appetizers became
a
a a an actual literal part of dinner
they they shouldn't be either it should
be the same thing for both you're right
but but if and i think it has to do with
placement
especially if you have an apps you don't
make it to dessert a lot of times and so
dessert gets the shaft because yeah that
started heavy with the apps but think
about like when you would go to your
grandmother's house like it would never
be like here's here's a [ __ ] pile of
spaghetti it would be like here's some
cheese let me cut up some sausage for
you know what i mean it's like homemade
oh see i associate more with all
grandma's bacon
you know
she's bacon she's baking dessert oh when
i go to grandma's house i'm like oh
dessert oh my grandmother maybe this is
where we're getting to my grandparents
they would have the box of you know with
the with the with the twine wrapped
around it from the local bakery oh yeah
i love all these that too yeah yeah but
oh come on my grandmother wouldn't make
it you see that white box from the
bakery with that red red and white twine
around it i you don't like any of that
stuff i never ate anything that's the
top of the sometimes i would take the
cream out of a cannoli but that was very
rare wow i just never liked them i
always thought they were oh man bakery
treats
bakery cookies stuff like that cannolis
it's like how do you not grab one
i just never got it one becomes two
rainbow cookie seven layer i i know
people love them i don't dislike them
but i i never want them okay wow yeah i
just never want them i don't know i just
don't have a sweet tooth
all right well babe that was a great
battle i uh i love that that was uh that
was a really i don't think we've had
um
a
focused
battle like that in a long time yeah
yeah we [ __ ] we usually [ __ ] but
a lot of times we don't really dig in to
all the theory and reasoning i think
that was really a technical battle well
yes you know i was following the format
yeah that was refreshing you know that
was really probably doesn't sometimes
sometimes now depending on the passion
we won't spend as much time dissecting
but i really like dissecting that okay
good yeah
he he you know i watch you guys like
he's got a lot of this
oh he's exasperated yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you know hopefully got a
different flavor
we did uh anything uh
anything to uh nothing as of yet uh you
know tell them steve dave podcast we do
it every week are you allowed to say uh
like are you allowed to like tease those
other big things that you're working on
or uh you know me i don't like saying
things okay okay you know i hate saying
something and then okay well it doesn't
happen all right well i'm excited for it
i got some cool things uh yeah so not
sure when this is out but i'm on tour
and uh go to savilicanocomedy.com all my
dates are up there they're all live
they're all for sale and if this is in
the near distant future thank you to
uh madison and albany and pittsburgh and
detroit and connecticut and
fudge chicago because we added second
shows in all of those cities because you
guys are coming out so thank you so much
i miss going on the road with you yeah i
miss it too i'm looking forward to like
us getting back out there
it's like because when you were saying
this and i was like i should come to
some of these shows i should fly out
just to hang out with them
yeah oh yeah we used to do that yeah we
did yeah it's uh well we are we are
getting back on that horse we had to you
know cancel the tour because it got
pushed around so many times and then it
just we just wasn't right and we needed
more of a runway to figure it out
because we weren't able to do shows in
the height of the pandemic
so uh we pushed it but uh hopefully 2022
we will have another announcement with
some new tour dates yeah yeah yeah
that'll be i actually look forward to
that so it'll be good yeah all right
well uh
i still love you oh you have to say to
me oh i still love you
i love you too that's nice i like that
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds